we can significantly reduce the waste by
getting rid of a massive problem in this
industry which is the problem of
mismatch between the expectations of of
a buyers Downstream in the supply chain
and what their base Supply Upstream so
by reducing the mismatch issue okay or
you you can diminish conservatively the
amount of waste in this industry thereby
also long-term driving down the price of
fruits and vegetables
to 20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Amir Whiteman an
experienced licensed investment advisor
and asset manager who has been involved
in Asset Management since 2004. from
2010 to 2017 he served as a senior
investment advisor for bankapalim
Israel's largest bank and in 2017 he
established Chapel Capital with Ari to
harness the power of Israeli technology
Investments he holds a Bachelor's of
arts and a masters in international
relations from the Geneva Graduate
Institute of international studies and
the Hebrew University of Jerusalem
[Music]
Amir Whiteman welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you
thank you great good to see you good to
see you too I'm really excited to dive
into your your journey over these 20
minutes and today with champo and in the
Venture Capital space for for quite some
time and and you know in investments in
general for for a long time uh you know
part of the time with the banker Pauline
working with also some uh management of
portfolios of some of some really
phenomenal people and and today with the
chapel capital and I'm especially also
excited to hear about the story of the
formation of Chapel Capital because I
understand that there's a little bit of
a personal story as well to it which
those are the stories that I love the
most and so Amir it's really good to
have you here and really good to to be
speaking to you tell me a little bit
about you know your own relationship
with an investing you know you chose to
go into the investment World why
well I you know I grew up in I was born
in Israel but I grew up in Switzerland
in Geneva I spent there 20 years
so you know when you come from Geneva
and you and you think you know what am I
going to do in my life then I guess
Finance banking slash all this world is
uh the most natural right because Geneva
is the world's capital in terms of asset
management probably one of the world's
capital in any case uh private banking
certainly so so since this is the case
um I when I was looking for a job that's
a while ago already I thought you know
what direction am I going to go into so
I thought you know let's do uh Let's do
let's become a portfolio manager which
is what I became and I worked there for
a few years then I went into banking
being an investment advisor in bangkokin
which is the largest Israeli bank and uh
but you know working in a bank is not
the most exciting uh job that you can
think of so I actually uh you know had
an opportunity early 2017 when my best
friend from where I grew up in
Switzerland we actually
were together are in kindergarten when
we were three years old literally and we
were in a primary school afterwards so
we remain in the same class for seven
years and then we stayed all our lives
best friends up to now so he actually
needed very well in life and uh and so
he said he called me early 2017 he said
listen you understand about Finance
about all this world uh you know let's
invest in the in the in the Israeli
starts of nation right uh in Israeli
Tech and
um and uh let's let's open our VC shops
we originally invested you know private
Capital his own and uh friends and
family and a few clients he grew with
doing well 3x out of the original 14
investment we have three Investments
which have exited already or forced one
about to exit the fifth one well on its
way so we we're doing well and so we
decided that you know that's how we
Advanced and but you know I time
Advanced we decided it's going to be
easier to have a full-fledged fund
instead of every time uh you know having
to essentially uh fundraise on a
day-by-day basis so we created our own
fund uh this January uh 10 months ago
and uh Carry On We're carrying on our
fundraising for for another one and
um yeah in this second fund we have
officially made already Farm investment
the fifth one about to be announced in
the Pro in the coming two three days so
I'm not gonna say anything yet because
it's not official yes but it's signed
and the sixth one hopefully next week so
uh there's action and uh I love I have
to say I love the tech world I love the
ventral world I think it's fascinating I
think that
um I'm bringing an interesting a bit
different uh experience coming from
Finance for me from Asset Management in
banking but
um I I think you know it's it's is
really Upstream when you think about VC
as opposed to Banking and finance right
and public market but it's really really
interesting and it's fascinating to see
the World of Tomorrow being shaped today
by entrepreneurs and you can see what
really drives the world you know and I I
remember of this book from Ayn Rand
about the Atlas Shrugged right the atlas
being the entrepreneur holding
mankind on his shoulders and and it's
true and I think it's true to a very
large extent because you can see how new
technologies are being created by the
most amazing people on Earth we've got
incredible ideas incredible abilities to
create new technologies new stuff which
eventually is going to improve
everybody's lives in every single
industry it's amazing to see it
happening in life
yet you need to focus as an investor you
need to focus on specific types of
entrepreneurs specific types of
investors what is your uh what is your
orientation I guess what what excites
you about the Investments that you make
great so
um I would say you know as you said you
have to focus so the world is great is
large there's there are great
entrepreneurs all over the world but we
are in Israel and uh Israel is by per
capita by father number one a VC
ecosystem in the world and even in
absolute terms it's one of the leading
ecosystems in the world there's plenty
of amazing entrepreneurs going around
here so we decided first of all to focus
geographically we're only doing Israeli
companies nothing else second of all in
terms of um where we are in terms of uh
being not you know we raised around 30
million dollars so we're not a very
large fund so I would say uh later stage
deals are off the table uh almost by
definition so we don't want to be in any
case in late in late stage uh this is
because we want to create a very
significant revenues uh not revenues
returns rather great all right and our
irr which are more difficult to to have
in later stages so biodeficion we
connect to have to go at an earlier
stage but not too early because I would
say precede and Seed are very very very
highly speculative right it's very
difficult so you need to find some sort
of a balance right between two being too
late too early so our sweet spot is
around series a bit before a bit after
but it's really series a when we see
that companies have bought already some
commercial traction when they've
Catholic your product when we can assess
the market and we kind of know where we
are
yeah
in in terms of the the areas that excite
you most you talked very candidly about
you know the building the future of
tomorrow and the chain you know worlds
changing and colliding what what you
know Are there specific things that you
can think about and say okay these are
things that I'm saying like wow these
really excite me I want to be a part of
the transformation in these industries
yes for sure so first of all I would say
we love agri-food
Agri Tech and food Tech because you know
this isn't we just stopped before we
started yeah we just talked about that
before we started it's in in it's really
when you think about it the world is
facing a huge challenge we have already
eight billion people on Earth uh within
you know the next 30 Years where we were
expected to to have the the perfect the
the the the population of the Earth
growing from eight to around 10 billion
people so this is a huge amount of
people and of course we need to feed all
these people and uh it's not only more
people on Earth it's also be uh sad
people's standards of living
thankfully uh being better increasing
which means that people who are I would
say on the lower end of the
socio-economic uh okay globally right so
poor people becoming less poor which
means they're going to eat more and
better so all this is really making uh
uh is creating a huge need in terms of
increased uh agricultural production
that's on one hand on the other hand is
people who you know who are conscious of
the fact that you know you need you need
to be careful with what you eat because
uh you know cardiovascular uh uh disease
is a number one uh killer in the world
uh uh you know you need to be it's
better we all understand that so uh and
there's also the the climatic challenge
of course the climate challenge uh you
know CO2 Etc so you need to to to have
ways of eating which are much more
sustainable we are an impact Fund in
that respect so let me give you two very
short example in food Tech we invested
in alif farms elephants is amazing it's
a company which is cultured meat so the
idea here is to have real meat and I I
ate it where there was the first the
first public tasting of the of of the
product or early November just three
weeks ago and we I took part in it it's
amazing it's good it's it's it's it's
completely meets uh just it doesn't come
from a cow it's just grown in a lab so
it's astounding because the you know
it's high quality it's it's it's really
everything you want from the meat just
not coming from a doubt from a gal so
you can cut 99 of the land use of the
water use of the energy use and have
your meat so that's an example in terms
of sustainability of course the the
advantage is great we have another
company where we invested both remote so
remilk is a company where you have
fashion you are duplicating uh the DNA
of milk so you create a milk proteins
which can give you dairy products which
are come which are coming from real milk
right it's not pretend milk it's not
like soya milk it's real milk just it's
not coming from a cow so again if you
get rid of 99 of their land Energy Water
Etc so so this is the sort of of of
stuff which which I find extremely
exciting it's transforming the way we
eat because we're taking uh creating new
products which are going to be tasty
because that's the first thing you want
when when you eat it is that it's tasty
but also healthy and sustainable that's
an example uh we also invested in a
company which you know this is the
company we spoke about before Clary
fruit which is doing essentially Q uh QR
QC uh quality control on fruits and
vegetables thereby reducing dramatically
uh the waste in in the food and
vegetable industry because or today
almost 45 percent of fruits and
vegetables are essentially lost in the
supply chain which is almost half when
you think about it it's completely crazy
so we can significantly reduce the waste
by uh getting rid of a massive problem
in this industry which is the problem of
mismatch between the expectations of of
uh buyers Downstream in the supply chain
and what their base Supply Upstream so
by reusing the mismatch issue or okay or
you you can diminish considerably the
amount of waste in this industry thereby
also long-term driving down the price of
fruits and vegetables
and how yeah this is life-changing one
of the things that that you mentioned um
another they saw you know when you're
talking about your work is that you're
really looking at the vision of
entrepreneurs let's talk about that a
little bit
um and because I think it connects
nicely to what you were talking about
before with your interest and you know
the the way that the future is changing
and unfolding uh through the
entrepreneurial landscape so let's talk
a little bit about Vision how you see
entrepreneurs you know working with
vision how you identify entrepreneurs
that are Visionary from those that
aren't necessarily as Visionary and what
types of Visions excite you personally
well as I said what does it mean to
trans you know transforming the world
but it's a big word what does it say so
what I like is is people who can imagine
a world which is different what's a
vision at the end of the race Imagining
the world looking at how it is now and
how it can be tomorrow if you do things
differently
right how do you solve problems and
create a new reality because that's what
we're talking about right so
um uh you know one company uh which is
solving a huge problem
um is
is a company where we have invested this
summer it's a company called indoor
robotics now the problem is that uh
you need to safeguard and uh indoor
spaces like offices like warehouses data
centers so you know plants whatever now
this is extremely expensive now what's
the problem with that is that it drives
up it makes everything more expensive so
all the production process is becoming
more expensive because of the way we
simply protect all these offices right
at the end of the day of course all
these expenses are being uh paid by the
the end clients right so so how do you
drive down uh security uh cost and and
thereby the whole production cost
because security is simply one if you
want what was some part of the
production cost or the global production
cost so by cutting the costs there for
the for the companies you can drive down
the cost for everything and make
everything uh really more efficient so
it's really making one item in the whole
production process cheaper and there's
an amazing solution that they have and I
think it's the only company in the world
which does that is to have these indoor
drones because you have thousands of
companies doing a of companies globally
which do drones right but how many
companies of out of these thousand
companies actually draw two drones
inside in in or in indoor spaces I don't
feel many of them and uh they have found
this crazy uh way of doing it by having
the drones also docking on the ceiling
and charging there and they're actually
patrolling in the in the indoor uh uh
indoor indoor spaces and in terms of
Robotics it's an amazing breakthrough
technologically and conceptually
and this will allow again to drive down
production costs by making uh uh by
making uh the whole Safety and Security
cost uh cheaper but again that's just
the first step because the second step
is that you can use this technology for
a lot of different applications so I
think in terms of Robotics uh uh it's
it's it you can see how robots are going
to make make human beings redundant in a
lot of uh of uh of applications or jobs
which is going to allow for for human
beings to do uh other jobs which with
higher uh added value therefore making
everybody wealthier so I think it's
amazing how how the economy Works how
technology Works in terms of vision I
think it's a great great company you can
see they have it and they're subsiding
they're succeeding they're signing
contracts uh huge contracts with clients
and it's a startup right and uh it's
really working so this is the sort of
stuff that you can see that it's going
to write Direction
yeah 100 I love that and and once once
you do partner with with entrepreneurs
what is the what is the relationship
like uh from your experience
well
I have to be blessed I can't tell you
something I have on our board we have
one of our of our med tech entrepreneurs
who we took as an Advisory board so I
think it just shows that uh oh I think
uh if uh that our entrepreneurs like
working with us because we love them so
you know generally when you love
somebody then love tends to be uh
two-way street right so when we hear we
we don't believe in micromanaging uh uh
companies we don't believe uh that our
job is to know better the entrepreneurs
uh about their job about their companies
about their markets right so if if we if
we would have thought that we simply
would not have invested in a company we
invested the company because we believe
in the team first and foremost of course
and therefore we see ourselves as simply
a neighbors and as people who are here
to help them succeed that's all I can't
do the job of of them of these
entrepreneurs they're all much smarter
than me so so I'm the dumb guy in the
street if you want so I'm I'm just here
to help them succeed and uh and opening
doors for them and and giving good
advice and you know with a lot of
experience already in terms of business
so I think our advice is sound and
helping raise Capital which we've done
for many companies and uh
um yeah this is what what the icr our
job was big and what is the the the best
part about your job if you had to think
about you know what makes you really
fulfilled and you know sort of why you
do what you do well what is really the
most fulfilling and and success in part
success success when you see that the
business is progressing that you're
creating value that your idea which when
you start at the company at this stage
is it's mostly an idea with as I said
little uh validation from the market but
when you see that actually real clients
who come and they say you know what your
product is good your service is good I
want it I'm willing to pay for it so
what you are seeing is that your vision
and the entrepreneur's vision is being
translated into reality I think that's
amazing
I like that I really really do because I
think that at the end it's um you know I
think that you know and it just comes up
throughout this whole conversation you
know sort of what your what Your where
your interests are and how excited you
are and the details in which you go in
here with the companies that you work
with I think really shine light on you
know how how invested you are not not
just Capital but in terms of you know
energy and and then mentally into the
companies that you're with I think about
it all the time I worked about all the
time it's it's it's it's really
incredible but it's great I loved it I
really love it Amir I really want to
thank you for these 20 minutes highly
highly appreciate it and wishing you a
best of luck with Chapel capital and I
love the story of how it started and who
you're doing it with and going all the
way back to kindergarten Switzerland and
obviously the journey along the way in
the motivation so thank you very very
much the best of luck and stay safe and
stay healthy YouTube